little box on the hillside little boxes
made of ticky tacky little boxes on the
side and they all look just the same you
want to control your life but life isn't
a science experiment you can't contain
your world forever try doing one thing
that scares you over break okay yeah
this serves as an entry voucher for
mimics escape rooms room yet and win a
million dollars so uh one does the game
start I think this is the escape room we
should look for clues what are we
looking for here anything that looks
like a puzzle or code it looks like an
oven dial that's creepy as hell
is it getting hotter how do we get out
of here it's burning for 15 months
let's talk about a person what's wrong
with you that was real
Wow
dumb question are we outside sooner get
this figured out so you'll get the hell
out of here
watching us you know everyone's Ulrika
everything about us this is my hospital
bed me too
they made these rooms for us I've never
seen things that weren't there before
that's why they chose us and they all
look just
[Music]